bom dia meu nome é fato escopeta
eu sou dependente inteligência
artificial
ela só eu não sou o único nessa sala
então me faça um favor
levante a mão quem consumiu algum tipo
de inteligência artificial nas últimas
24 horas mantém quem fez uma busca na
internet google no bin
mas alguns quem acessou as suas
atualizações nas redes sociais é uma
olhada na tanzânia ou que o sistema
estava sugerindo a quem assistir um
filme no netflix dedicado só pra você
uma música spotify quem entrou no tinga
bem é importante é você que levantou a
mão com essa nova rotina você levantou
em outro momento rafael e seu nome
gisele eu fábio rafael e há gisele assim
como todos vocês nessa sala todos nós
temos alguma dependência já algum nível
de dependência de aplicações baseadas em
inteligência artificial mas falar de
inteligência artificial ou qualquer
tecnologia não tem qualquer valor
a gente não associar a resolução de um
problema que seja relevante para a
humanidade
ou então pelo menos a criação de uma
nova visão para um desafio que a gente
tenha então a visão que eu vou usar de
exemplo pra gente aqui hoje é a minha
visão de como deveria ser a saúde de
novo eu eo rafael e gisele gente deveria
ter todas as informações relevantes para
a nossa saúde disponíveis a qualquer
momento sejam as nossas nossos dados
genéticos nossos dados clínicos de
integrar a interação com diversas áreas
da saúde hospitais e consultórios
os nossos dados contextuais e
comportamentais tudo que é relevante
para nossa saúde de algum tipo de
inteligência que nos ajudaria a tomar as
melhores decisões para evitar uma doença
ou então procurar uma doença que a gente
já tenha adquirido ou para melhorar a
nossa qualidade de vida
caso a gente tem alguma doença crônica
que nós estamos vivendo cada vez mais
isso é uma visão do futuro
não é uma visão do presente que a gente
ainda não ver toda a tecnologia
necessária para implementar para
materializar essa visão ela está
disponível
qual é o ponto fundamental da nossa
acção hoje como democratizar essa
tecnologia como fazer com que ela chegue
a qualquer um de nós dentro e fora desta
sala a gente entender como que funciona
o processo de democratização de da
tecnologia a gente vai fazer uma longa
viagem no tempo
vamos voltar a 1.450
neste momento sim ventava se a prensa
móvel na europa ocidental volta dessa
data existiam três mil livros impressos
ou alguma coisa parecida
cinquenta anos depois da invenção da
prensa existiam 15 milhões de
publicações na mesma região
note que neste momento experimentou a
primeira grande movimentação em direção
à democratização da informação do acesso
a ela e da criação mas eu diria que o
momento definitivo foi um pouco mais
adiante já na nossa geração
em 1989 a internet
neste momento a questão da
democratização do acesso e da criação a
de dados de informação atingiu níveis
que a gente nunca tinha imaginado mas
também nesse mesmo momento passou a
enfrentar um problema um problema bom
para ser sócio é solucionado mas ainda
assim é um grande desafio como extrair
valor de toda essa informação a que está
disponível para nós
claramente ela tá já os níveis de
quantidade de informação vai além do que
a nossa capacidade cognitiva seria a
capaz de processar
nesse momento a gente passa a ter um
tipo de informação que ela é muito
particular
é o que a gente chama de informação e
estruturada é toda a informação que a
gente gera para se comunicar entre nós
humanos
isso porque os computadores clássicos
são tão bons assim para interpretar o
que são informações desestruturadas são
nossos posts espero que vocês estejam
aceitando as nossas imagens a imagem à
do rafael no instagram os nossos vídeos
do ted é tudo que o ser humano usa para
se comunicar entre si que não
necessariamente faz pra a processar numa
máquina que está aí o valor do dólar e
com isso a gente chega um ponto em que
os problemas que a gente pode resolver
diante de toda essa disponibilização de
informação são problemas bem mais
complexos do que a gente resolvia
antigamente os sistemas tradicionais
sistemas computados computacionais
tradicionais temas ou aplicativos
[Música]
baseados em conjunto de regras bem
definidas
eu vou dar um exemplo pra vocês um
problema complexo que a gente não
consegue resolver com regras fixas
câncer câncer é um problema muito
sofisticado e por ser tão sofisticado a
gente estuda muito esse problema
a todo momento a gente tem uma uma nova
novo medicamento é inventado uma
combinação de medicamentos existentes
que traz uma nova reação você tem casas
particulares de cada a ser humano que
reage a um protocolo diferente ou seja a
informação que é criada em torno do
assunto cansa é muito grande um
colorista para se manter atualizado com
lojistas
deveria estudar por volta de 150 a 200
horas por semana alguém aqui tem é esse
o tempo disponível
o lojista também não são gente passa a
precisar
[Música]
nova está a arquitetura computacional
uma nova forma de pensar as aplicações
do dia a dia a gente precisa desses
temas que aprendem e quando digo
sistemas que aprendem são os temas que
são capazes de aumentar nossa capacidade
intelectual nos dar mais inteligência e
com a aumentar nosso poder cognitivo e
por isso muitas vezes a gente chama a
esse sistema de sistemas cognitivos ou
aplicações cognitivas e essas aplicações
tem três características fundamentais
vocês aprender essas três vocês sabem
explicar os objetivos para qualquer
pessoa a mesa de jantar para os nossos
pais filhos avós
a primeira característica é ligada ao
assunto que eu levantei relação a dados
desestruturados que é a informação
os textos que o médico escreve quando eu
vou consultar com ele ou então a avós
todos os dados que a gente troca por voz
dentro do consultório ou as imagens de
algum exame que eu faça e que entendam
que tudo isso a informação
desestruturada ea gente precisa desses
temas são capazes de entender esse tipo
de linguagem dele uma imagem um raio x e
vê que tem uma anomalia lá ou então
escutar o médico falando com o paciente
está o fábio a relatando algum algum
sintoma e entender do que se trata é
obra dá um exemplo prático ou a
tecnologia de reconhecimento de voz da
microsoft há duas semanas atingiu o
mesmo nível de compreensão do ser humano
é tecnologia que alimenta o cortando ou
acordando
a segunda característica é é aprender
então quando eu disse e a gente já não
consegue programar um sistema para nos
ajudar a curar o câncer
a gente passa a precisar de um sistema
que a prenda que consiga ler milhões e
milhões de artigos de páginas publicadas
sobre essa doença entenda sobre ela e
como esses sistemas são ensinados
eu falei que eles aprendem alguém tem
que ensinar é por aí mesmo é bem
parecido com o ser humano a gente tem
imagine um médico
é o especialista seguir o professor um
sistema como esse
ele vai ensinar o que é certo eo que é
errado eu passei bem prático pensamos em
fazer um upload imenso milhões de
páginas de informação e aí você tem um
professor pode ser um médico
especialista 11 time é que diz o que é
certo e errado para aquele sistema e
assim como ser humano depois que a gente
vai pra escola a gente continua
aprendendo
pela nossa experiência a gente dar uma
resposta ao mundo ele nos responde de
forma positiva ou negativa a gente vai
ficar mais ou menos a confiante naquela
aquele conhecimento que a gente tem na
resposta a que a gente deve ter é mais
ou menos por aí pensa em ensinar um
sistema cognitivo a gente ensina de
forma supervisionada com um professor um
especialista de forma não supervisionada
pela experiência e finalmente a terceira
característica exibir algum tipo de
raciocínio o que isso quer dizer
são capazes de ler toda essa informação
e está aí hipóteses de encontrar padrões
adianta nada um grande sistema milhões
de páginas nos ajudar a aumentar nossa
característica de democratização então
como que a gente leva essa tecnologia
para todos nós
primeiro em inteligência artificial
muitas vezes é pensar em
supercomputadores errado hoje a com a
computação cognitiva inteligência
artificial ela está disponível na nuvem
em forma de lápis para quem não sabe
oque são pequenos trechos que resolvem é
o trecho de código resolve um problema
específico bem a contínua um serviço
então o que eu quero dizer com isso é
que qualquer um nessa sala onde saí
daqui ao final do evento entrar numa
plataforma na nuvem por exemplo azure e
construir um sistema de computação
cognitiva ensinar sobre qualquer assunto
por exemplo
acho que vocês podem entrar hoje na
zurich e criar um aplicativo que tenha
um reconhecimento facial que é
exatamente o mesmo que o vero usa pra
reconhecer os seus próprios motoristas
se percebe o nível da democratização da
tecnologia ela está disponível a todos
nós
para dar um exemplo aquilo que eu gosto
muito
eu posso reunir os melhores não colou
giz do brasil geralmente estão nos
grandes centros econômicos a fazer com
que eles ensinem os temas sobre
oncologia sobre câncer de mama e
disponibilizar esse mesmo sistema o
norte do maranhão uma comunidade carente
precisando apenas de uma internet pode
ser a rádio e um browser
isso é uma grande democracia são do
conhecimento não é uma visão de futuro e
presente a gente já tem sistemas como
esses funcionando em uma série de
lugares por exemplo a microsoft ibm hoje
treinam alguns aplicativos para entender
a genética do câncer sem se estender
sobre esse assunto é o câncer é
basicamente uma doença genética ou um
tumor é identificado pelas suas
anotações
então esses temas aprender e entender é
com essas mutações relacionam e tratar
esse tumor
do ponto de vista da genética e não
necessariamente de que órgão ele se
manifestou
outro exemplo são as sistemas de segunda
opinião eu acabei de falar que a
oncologistas precisaria estudar mais
horas do que a gente tem para se manter
atualizado então eu pensei em sistemas
hoje que lêem milhões de páginas tudo
que é publicado diariamente e pode
promover uma segunda opinião dá uma
opinião para o profissional pra que
baseada em evidências para aquele
profissional a aaa não tenha necessidade
- cubra a aaa
o gap da falta de tempo da falta da
nossa falta é poder cognitivo para
processar milhões de páginas diariamente
é outras opções
monitoram o eletrônico
quem é que não tem um idoso em sua
família que precisa ser monitorado que
causa uma preocupação a família então a
gente tem hoje sistemas que monitoram
por exemplo um diabético e tenta
antecipar uma crise indicam por paciente
que ele deve tomar alguma ação alguns
alguns aplicativos que aprenderam a ler
é um exame consegue é e interpretar uma
mamografia e tv que aquele nova pode ser
é benigno ou não portanto a democrata é
a democratização da informação eo acesso
a ela no caso da saúde o cenário a que o
início da apresentação com a gisele com
rafael
a partir do momento em que essa visão se
for materializada a gente passa a viver
num ecossistema que é montado o que tem
é o paciente ou a pessoa como o
principal objeto
hoje toda a área da saúde ela é
organizado em volta da doença é o inglês
também soube sequer na medida em que
todos os participantes desse ecossistema
sejam as universidades o governo
hospitais profissionais pontos que as
famílias todos que compõem esse
ecossistema compartilharem dados de
forma segura e trabalharem de forma
integrada a gente realmente vai
experimentar é o conceito de health care
a gente pensava inteligência artificial
alguns anos essa é a imagem que vinha à
mente
em algum momento terminator a skynet
acharia que é uma boa idéia de destruir
a raça humana por qualquer fosse motivo
o caso do matrix nos transformar em
baterias
o fato é que essa imagem do passado que
foi muito alimentada pelo imaginário
entre óleo de óbvio que essa é uma
discussão é de muitas horas
mas o ponto que eu quis trazer hoje aqui
a visão está se materializando há muito
mais a próxima peça do guerreiro da dise
em que existem há aplicações em vez de
aprender sobre
o universo ela se especializa em uma
determinada área por exemplo oncologia a
nos ajudam a tomar as melhores decisões
para cuidar da nossa saúde e para
vivermos melhor
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]